a new app that allows instagram users to
send anonymous messages is soaring in
popularity and renewing concerns about
cyber bullying and harassment that
plagued previous apps which allowed
teens to comment on one another
anonymously
the app called ngl q a was developed by
a company called deepmoji the app
invites followers to share anonymous
feedback via a link on instagram stories
that goes into the app's inbox
according to data.ai ngo which is an
abbreviation for not gonna lie has seen
five million downloads as of june 27
2022 with 2.39 million on google play
and 2.57 million on ios
ngl follows in the footsteps of websites
and apps like ask.fm whisper and yolo
that have built huge audiences by
allowing teenagers to vent privately on
social media before facing a public
backlash over child safety fears
instagram briefly blocked links to the
ngl app on june 22nd but is now active
again deep emoji says its artificial
intelligence powered content moderation
protects young users from harmful
content deepmoji did not respond for
multiple requests for comment the rise
of ngl tracks with the growth and the
collapse of earlier anonymous messaging
apps that had become popular with teens
one app called sarahah was pulled by
apple and google from their respective
app stores over claims and enabled cyber
bullying the ceo of another company
called secret voluntarily shut down the
app in 2015 after admitting his team
could not control abuse and harassment
on the platform
in saraja's case the developers banned
children from its service and promised
to step up moderation
ngl's explosive growth over the last
month has piggybacked on the popularity
of instagram with young people it also
follows snap suspending rival apps yolo
and ymk in may 2021 after being hit with
a still pending lawsuit claiming that
they broke consumer protection laws in a
case involving the suicide of an oregon
teen in june 2020. instagram itself is
currently facing criticisms for its
effects on teens and the presence of
child predators on its platform in june
meta announced it would introduce checks
using facial recognition technology to
make sure instagram users who are
allowed to join from age 13 are shown
age-appropriate content
instagram declined to comment on the ngl
app